by the way mayor garcetti just announced
two dozen cities are announcing their
own ubi 500
a month they want to pay to the
low-income families
in l.a los angeles the country's second
largest city merigar said he has pledged
to launch a program that includes a mix
of public and private money
he hinted the program could also help
immigrants
living in the country illegally who have
been written out of federal legislation
in los angeles the county said
okay but so you wrote the same thing
twice and copy paste okay got that so
so you got 500 500
a month 500 a month that he wants to pay
out as his own form of ubi
two dozen cities are agreeing to this
who does this help
who does this hurt who should care who
shouldn't care
the taxpayers should definitely care um
and i think we didn't we just do this
experiment with uh with
unemployment during covet and stimulus
checks didn't we just do
this experiment and and how many people
didn't want to go back to work
because they made too much money on
unemployment two thirds of people were
getting paid
more to sit at home than they were when
working
i mean it's you know and and then it's
it's companies
i think maybe a lot like yours that
suffer people don't want to come back to
work
you know and it's you know you're going
to go where the money is
to me that seems very counterproductive
and what was what was what is
stimulating this decision like what is
what you know who is he
we already have a myriad of programs
uh to help low-income people i don't
understand
why we why we need to continue to add on
top of that and i'm not saying that you
know
i'm not saying that you know poor people
are lazy that's not where i'm getting
from and that's not what i'm getting at
you know circumstances happen
i'm just wondering why these current
programs that we have don't seem to be
filling the void yeah you know i'm not
so how many other cities other than la
have 25 cities paterson new jersey has
also pledged to follow a similar program
uh you're talking about oakland uh mount
vernon
some places in new york tacoma
washington paterson jersey long beach
some other areas
okay let's let's play a little game real
quick on where we are on
ubi right universal basic income yeah
i'm like 70 30 meaning
i'm 70 no 30
okay let me i see some benefits with
this all right let's list the pros and
cons and i'd love to get your responses
so what are the cons right the cons are
obviously it encourages
laziness it encourages people not to go
back to work uh disincentivizes work
illegals maybe potential crim criminals
just straight up losers would be getting
money to sit at home
and obviously taxpayers socialism big
government
there's a lot of bad on ubi what's the
good what's the good so obviously
people can avoid slipping into poverty
homelessness
some people could potentially have that
money to pay their bills maybe take more
risks start more businesses
that's an opportunity right there um and
then obviously the big thing that andrew
yang talks about
is automation and robots are going to be
coming for your jobs
in the next 10 20 30 40 years so there's
pros and cons to this so i'm 70 30
um against ubi but i'm not 100 against
ubi
what say you to me a ubi
screams uh i can't compete in the world
it's green you know it screams it's not
encouraging people
to go into the trades which is so
necessary right now
okay so yeah so we're we're doing this
this whole
you know i think when when i was in high
school and you know during my college
years it was like you got to go to
college you're a loser
okay and then the trades suffered for it
right so
you know um you know welders and
gunsmithing and you know we get finding
a good mechanic god help us can we find
a good mechanic
you know what i mean and so all that
stuff suffered
and now the trades are making a comeback
totally agree and i think that um
you know if we if we say you know we're
going to give out this universal
basic income it's really just proving
that
all of your programs that you've done
before before this
have failed because they're out there
okay and you can and you can
take advantage of them so why do we need
this additional one we're
disincentivizing people
to either start businesses you know
there's micro loan programs and loan
programs for people who want to start
businesses
um and and then you know we don't we
don't we're not encouraging anybody to
think for themselves do for themselves
or
go into the much needed trades i'm i'm
in the trades
i'm in gunsmithing where are you on the
on the are you 100
80 90 50 like where are you on the i'm
zero percent
because we already have we already have
programs in place are you also zero
percent
let me tell you what i love about it i
love i love
that garcetti announces five hundred
dollars to l.a you have no idea how much
i love it
tell ask me why i love it pat pat let me
tell you why
i want to ask you go ahead pat why do
you love it
let me tell you why i love it jay i'm
gonna tell you why i love it
and it's gonna be a different
perspective but i love
this stupidity of what la's about to do
do it go for it give people free money
here's what it's going to do look you
know what i'm all about is the following
okay if if taking off if you
if you they say a very simple line
says if you don't take care of your
people somebody else will
right it's that simple now you know
you're going to lose certain people
culturally they fit in a different
culture etc etc
but if you don't take care of your
people somebody else will if you don't
take care of your woman
somebody else will if you don't take
care of your man someone else will
there's always going to be somebody else
that's
willing to take care of what you
currently have it's that simple right
okay
you know la has a choice to offer this
ubi program to the people that they want
who's it going to attract
so imagine if you are in a different
county
and your county doesn't give you 500
okay
say i am the mayor of a complete
different city
i'm a mayor of a completely different
county different city that i'm running
it
and la announces they're giving 500
guess who's leaving my city
i'm in love i'm like mayor garcetti
thank you
thank you because everybody that wants
free money and are moving to your county
thank you for cleaning out my county i'm
all with it
because i'm not going to lose my
business owners to your county oh no i'm
going to lose the people that want free
money to your county
i appreciate you phenomenal job thank
you so much for doing this
you